it's tasty a little bit squishy totally
delightful and even better if toasted my
name is rich Hyndman
and I'm going to delve into the fluffy
center of our latest Android offering
and the new hardware that forms the
latest Nexus lineup so Android
marshmallow numerically its Android 6
and for developers that's API 23 it's
the most stable efficient and feature
packed version of Android yet and the
first two devices to launch with the
latest hotness are the Nexus 5x and
Nexus 6p the Nexus 5x is a delight built
in partnership with LG it's equipped
with a 5.2 inch 1080p display a
Snapdragon 808 processor and a 12 point
three megapixel rear camera
it offers top-of-the-line performance in
a compact lightweight device third
developers there were two new
intermediate densities added an API 23
density 360 and density 420 and the new
Nexus 5x is in that latter bucket
so for devs that are using compatible
screen declaration in their manifest
you're gonna need to test your app out
and add the new values the Nexus 6p
built with her huawei rocks a 5.7 inch
high-resolution AMOLED display
front-facing stereo speakers and a 12
point three megapixel rear camera all
housed in a contoured aluminium body I
absolutely love these devices and both
have USB C port and fingerprint sensors
the updates in marshmallow are primarily
targeted towards improving the user
experience smoothing out install an
update flows speeding up authentication
improving battery life adding
contextually sensitive controls and
allowing applications to assist each
other at a deeper level than ever before
arguably one of the biggest changes in M
has to be the arrival of runtime
permissions while this reduces friction
for install and updates it does come
with some overhead you can no longer
assume that just because your app is
installed that all its stated
permissions have been granted
permissions are now granted at runtime
and users can revoke permissions on a
per app basis at any time there are more
details in Nick butchers video on
permissions UI in an effort to simplify
robust data backup for developers and
also simplify the lives of users Android
auto backup ensures up to 25 megabytes
of data is backed up per app if your
project targets M
backup will automatically be enabled and
there are a couple of things you should
be aware of so be sure to check out the
docs and watch Matthews video for full
details something I'm personally very
excited about there are a number of
battery optimizations in marshmallow but
the biggest individual contributors are
doze and app standby if a user leaves
their device unplugged and stationary
for a period of time and the screen is
off then the device is going to enter
doze mode it's going to stay in that
sleep state until the device is
disturbed by default some restrictions
apply to apps in this mode wait clocks
may be ignored scheduled alarms can be
deferred and network access may be
disabled but if you have good reason to
wake your app then you can do so on
Joanna Smith has just released a video
explaining it all there are new
authentication and security
possibilities with the addition of the
fingerprint recognition API with new
support and a TB testing command you can
help your users have the most secure
device as possible
Maya has the full details in her video
if you want to make it easy for users to
transition from your web content to your
app content app linking lets you take
control of the web content that you own
and voytek has a video that explains it
beautifully on top of that we have
Bluetooth stylus support text selection
context-aware pop-ups adoptable storage
and that assist api which allows you to
integrate with services built by other
developers not strictly part of
marshmallow but definitely worth
mentioning is the introduction of data
binding it's an Android studio feature
from 1.3 onwards and it reduces the
amount of code you need to write to hook
up your xml layout with your activities
CNET own video for the lowdown there
have also been updates to the support
library with a number of new libraries
including custom tabs percentage base
layout recommendations and preferences
with all the new goodness come some
goodbyes first up a deprecated API has
been removed Apache HTTP was deprecated
a while back in favor of the more
efficient HTTP URL connection and it's
been removed in Android 6 if your app or
any of the library use rely on it you're
going to need to make a small update to
include it in your build and declare it
in your build up Gradle file even though
OpenSSL was never part of the public NDK
api some apps still linked against
it and now that Android has switched
from open SSL to boring SSL yep that's
the name it means that those apps will
now break if you're in this situation
you need to get testing all the videos
mentioned here are available in our
Android marshmallow playlist so that's
Android marshmallow something harmless
and lovable that could never possibly
run amok in new york and destroy us